i'm natalie fay and i'm the founder of  city to see  [Music]  we're a not-for-profit campaigning to  stop plastic pollution at source  [Music]  we tend to campaign on the top 10  most commonly found plastic items on our  beaches things like plastic bottles and  bottle top caps and we do that primarily  through our refill campaign  [Music]  a cheeky little refill  [Music]  we also developed an app which is  stopping hundreds of millions of pieces  of plastic from entering the waste  stream connecting people to places they  can refill their water bottle they can  refill their household goods and coffee  cups and things like that as well  i'm working towards a future in which  plastic on beaches and plastic harming  our marine animals becomes a thing of  the past and we have designed pointless  plastic out of the waste system  and we are refilling our way to a truly  circular economy